[Musique]
rome ville éternelle à laquelle selon
l'expression tous les chemins mènent
[Musique]
niché au coeur de rome à deux pas des
rives du tibre se trouve l'un des plus
précieux trésor de notre civilisation
l'un des endroits les plus remarquables
de la planète
[Musique]
ce haut lieu de la chrétienté n'est
autre que le siège du saint-siège
résidence des papes et gouvernement
central de l'église catholique
la cité du vatican 1 royaume à une seule
ville dans la capitale et à l'intérieur
de l'italie un lieu singulier ou humain
et divin se rejoignent les se touchent
presque
oh
depuis près de deux mille ans ce
minuscule territoire joue un rôle
capital dans les relations
internationales
empreint de majesté et de mystère ce
reliquat des états pontificaux est un
endroit magique où gloire divine et
pouvoir spirituel s'entremêlent où les
frontières entre légende et réalité se
confondent souvent un univers où l'on
pénètre pour une visite une prière mais
dont peu de secret nous ont été dévoilés
[Musique]
place saint pierre porte de la cité du
vatican une entrée qu'empruntent chaque
année des millions de fidèles
la traversée de cette place symbolise à
elle seule le franchissement d'une
frontière séparant l'italie du vatican
la cité du vatican est en effet un état
souverain et indépendant
à l'abri derrière l'ancienne muraille
cette terre sainte d'une superficie de
44 hectares a beau rester le plus petit
état du monde
elle continue depuis des millénaires
d'influencé l'histoire de l'humanité
[Musique]
car le vatican est un monde à part un
royaume où passé et présent cohabitent
harmonieusement et où foi religieuse et
pouvoir politique font bon ménage
un lieu béni où l'on exerce ses voeux de
pauvreté parmi les plus prodigieuses
collection d'oeuvres d'art et
d'architecturé de la civilisation
occidentale
[Musique]
cette vaste place saint-pierre est en
soi un carrefour international ses
colonnades s'ouvre en une embrassade
fraternel aux pèlerins touristes et
amoureux du monde entier qui convergent
chaque jour verrait elle est le seuil de
la résidence du pape
l'un des personnages les plus influents
qui soit
[Musique]
juste derrière les murs à colonnades de
la place se dresse la chapelle sixtine
savut abrite des peintures parmi les
plus célèbres du monde
des fresques éblouissante née du génie
de michel-ange
c'est aussi dans cet édifice que se
tiennent les fameux conclave a semblé
secrète est étroitement surveillée au
sein desquels on élit chaque nouveau
pape
[Musique]
ces gardes suisses arborant des couleurs
vives forme la minuscule armée du
vatican créé il ya cinq siècles comme la
garde rapprochée des souverains pontifes
la garde suisse compte ou juste sans
solde
leurs uniformes violet et or ainsi que
leurs armes sont identiques à ceux que
ce corps d'élite porté à la renaissance
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de la basilique saint
pierre de rome se déroulent les offices
religieux selon la tradition catholique
romaine
saint pierre et la plus majestueuse
église de la chrétienté merveille de
technicité dans toute l'histoire de
l'architecturé son dôme grandiose marque
le dernier exploit de la prestigieuse
carrière de michel-ange
[Musique]
mais le plus précieux de tous les
trésors du vatican est sans conteste le
tombeau absolument unique qu'abrite en
sous-sol la basilique
la légende veut qu'il y a près de 2000
ans bien avant qu'on y érige la
basilique
ce lieu est accueilli la sépulture de
saint pierre sans le récit de la vie
édifiante et du martyre de ce disciple
du christ le vatican
loin de rayonner sa puissance et sa
gloire sur le monde chrétien serait
resté un champ presque anonyme de ruines
romaines toute l'église catholique
repose sur les fondations de la
basilique saint pierre
les gens s'intéressent aux personnages
de saint-pierre et l'aiment parce qu'ils
étaient à leur image c'était un simple
pêcheur
il a même été mariée c'était un homme
généreux et fidèle mais il avait comme
tout être humain ses défauts et ses
faiblesses
il a péché il a même tourné le dos au
christ et il a souvent douté au point de
perdre la foi à plusieurs reprises mais
en définitive c'est en véritable martyre
de jésus qu'il est mort
comment pour autant l'héritage spirituel
d'un humble pêcheurs parviendra-t-il à
inspiré autant de magnificence pour
comprendre l'état pontifical tel que
nous le connaissons aujourd'hui
il faut remonter en arrière à l'époque
de la rome antique
il y à un peu moins de 2000 ans la
capitale actuelle de l'italie était une
puissante métropole de près d'un million
d'habitants
lorsque pierre y arrive pour établir une
église ou dire l'évangile de jésus rome
est alors à la tête du plus grand empire
que le monde ait connu sa civilisation
compte des architectes et bâtisseurs
chevronnés d armée aguerrie de puissants
gouverneurs ainsi qu'une quantité
phénoménale de religion rassemblant des
dizaines de divinités d'origine
égyptienne grecque ou rapporter d'autres
conquêtes
[Musique]
l'apparition d'un nouveau culte a donc
toutes les chances de passer inaperçu
pourtant l'église chrétienne se démarque
bientôt des autres religions
alors que la loi romaine exigent qu'on
fasse ses dévotions à l'empereur les
nouveaux chrétiens refusent de s'y plier
néron souverains et des spots de
sinistre mémoire vis ce rejet comme un
terrible affront
néron est alors très populaire auprès
des classes ouvrières de rome qu'il sait
amadouer de spectaculaires courses de
chars et autres combats sanglants de
gladiateurs jusqu'à ce qu'un désastre
viennent frapper la capitale faisant
éclater toute la démesure de l'empereur
l'événement déclencheur du mouvement de
révolte contre onéreux l incendie qui
s'est déclaré en juillet 64 après
jésus-christ un tiers de la ville a été
ravagée par les flammes et un deuxième
tiers a été sérieusement endommagé rome
avait beau connaître des incendies
dévastateurs
elle n'avait jamais subi d'une telle
gravité
mais au lieu de reconstruire les
quartiers sinistrés néron se fait bâtir
à leur place un palais monumental
bientôt la rumeur envahi les rues
l'empereur mégalomane aurait lui même
déclenché la catastrophe
[Musique]
cherchant un bouc émissaire néron décide
de s'en prendre aux chrétiens
il envoie ses soldats perquisitionnaient
chaque demeure s'engage alors une
épouvantable vague de persécutions
les rassembler et puis on les
exécutaient certains ont même fini
ligoté aspergé de pétrole et brûlé comme
torche humaine pour éclairer un banquet
nocturne donné par néron un déchaînement
de cruauté qui culmine dans un lieu
connu sous le nom de cirque de néron
proche de l'emplacement où se dresse
aujourd'hui la basilique saint pierre
[Musique]
au centre de l'arène trône un imposante
obélisque égyptien la légende veut que
pierre et ses disciples étaient éconduit
enchaîné dans l'arène
puis crucifié avec des clous pierre à
l'envers sur une croix inversée
les romains ont voulu des peines
exemplaires il fallait que ce soit non
seulement à trausse physiquement mais en
même temps le plus humiliant possible
pourtant très tôt l'église catholique
racontera que c'est au contraire par
humilité que pierre fut ainsi crucifix
saint-pierre été crucifié à l'envers
parce qu'il avait déclaré ne pas être
digne de mourir sur une croix comme le
seigneur est probablement que sa
dernière vision a été cet obélisque on
descend ensuite son corps pour le cacher
dans un cimetière payen situé sur une
colline surplombant le cirque de néron à
l'époque second s'appelle vaticanus le
lieu d vaticinations où par définition
l'endroit où l'on prophétise sous
l'effet d'une inspiration surnaturel nul
ne sait encore toute l'importance que ce
site s'apprête à revêtir
[Musique]
peu à peu la sépulture de pierre le
martyre attire de plus en plus de
pèlerins transmis discrètement de bouche
à oreille le mot vaticanus devient le
lieu sacré où reposent pierre si
aujourd'hui la place qui porte son nom
accueille à bras ouverts les fidèles
c'est au péril de leur vie que pendant
les deux siècles et demi qui suivent la
crucifixion de pierre les premiers
chrétiens rendront leur culte
malgré le danger qu'il court à honorer
une religion déclaré hors la loi une
série de chef spirituel
ap les évêques assure la succession de
l'apôtre crucifié si bientôt la plupart
des villes de lempire possèdent leurs
églises et leurs évêques celui de rome
se voit gratifié d'un peu plus de
respect en prenant pour surnom il papa
le père le pape
les premiers pape deviennent alors les
représentants d'une religion souterraine
au sens figuré comme au sens propre les
catacombes vaste nécropole creusé sous
la capitale se démarque comme le refuge
idéal pour exercer et vivre librement
son culte
[Musique]
peu à peu on y taillé dans la roche
tendre des chapelles en hommage aux
martyrs et aux papes qui sont ensevelis
c'est aussi là que les croyants peignent
des fresques et grave des inscriptions
en mémoire des chrétiens décédé malgré
la persécution les rangs de l'église
s'allonge au début du 4e siècle les pas
des fidèles ont d'ores et déjà tracé une
voie aussi instinctive que discrète vers
vaticanus sites clandestins de la
sépulture de pierre
[Musique]
si la chrétienté demeure interdite il
faut attendre l'an 312 pour qu'un
événement de taille viennent placer au
centre de la scène internationale cette
humble lieu de pèlerinage
une lutte acharnée pour l'héritage du
pouvoir au poste depuis six ans deux
grands rivaux
l'empereur constantin premier legrand à
la tête de l'espagne de la gaule et de
la bretagne et maxence alors empereur de
rome en 312 espérons finir une fois pour
toutes
constantin lancé armée sur rome après
avoir renversé son adversaire au pont
milvius il révélera plus tard que sa
prière aux dieux païens du soleil fut
exaucé par l'apparition d'une croix dans
le ciel avec ces mots in oxydes nos une
caisse tu vaincras par ce signe
constantin premier a juré qu'il avait
bel et bien eu cette apparition en
compagnie de son armée certains pensent
qu'il s'agissait simplement d'un effet
d'optique causés par le soleil
toujours est il qu'il a fait peindre à
ces soldats ce symbole chrétien sur leur
bouclier et quand ils ont donné l'assaut
ils l'ont fait comme une armée
combattants sous la bannière de la
chrétienté
cette bataille a été une défaite totale
pour maxence avec le massacre de ses
soldats est lui-même jeté en armure dans
le tibre où il s'est noyé constanta
interprète sa victoire comme un signe
favorable du dieu des chrétiens
une victoire qui l'incitent à renoncer à
la politique de persécution de ses
prédécesseurs et à établir par les zi de
milan la liberté religieuse
le fait que consentent un premier était
un homme abject doublé d'un fou
sanguinaire il y avait tué ses fils et
sa femme
c'est lui qui a mis un terme à la
persécution des chrétiens
sans lui on se serait enlisé dans une
ère de chaos de guerre civile de meurtre
sans aucune morale sans chrétienneté le
monde n'aurait pas survécu
quand bien même au dernier instant sur
son lit de mort l'empereur lui-même se
convertira au christianisme
entre temps ils comblent l'église
d'argent de terre et de cadeaux sa plus
grande réalisation restera la première
ou ancienne basilique saint pierre
bâti sur le mont vaticanus en l'honneur
de l'apôtre si son chantier s'avère un
véritable cauchemar pour le sol très
argileux du site
cette oeuvre restera à jamais comme le
symbole le plus remarquable de
l'officialisation de la chrétienté
constantin premier était convaincu que
st-pierre avait été enterré à cet
endroit à droite de l'église
il y avait jadis une butte dont le
sommet est arrivé à sa hauteur en 324 au
lieu de faire construire sa basilique à
gauche de 7 buts
ou bien à droite il a tenu à ce qu'on a
bâtie sans eau ça lui a pris presque
deux ans de chantier et 800 ouvriers
il a fallu faire un énorme travail de
terrassement à flanc de coteau pour
pouvoir aplanir le terrain et construire
la basilique qui voulait juste au dessus
de la sépulture de saint pierre
[Musique]
si pendant près de trois siècles à rome
la flamme de la foi vacille jamais elle
ne s'éteint on peut même dire qu'elle
s'intensifie qu'elle gagne en clarté
comme en chaleur au point que l'empereur
lui-même accepte de s'y réchauffer et
d'y prier
paradoxalement avec la conversion
religieuse de constantin premier le
christianisme s'apprête à vivre un
incroyable revers de fortune cette
époque signe en effet la fin du seul
pouvoir spirituel de l'église au profit
de pouvoir également militaires et
politiques exercées par l'archevêque de
rome le pape au cours des siècles qui
suivent le vatican devient ainsi un
détour obligé pour les dirigeants les
plus puissants du monde occidental
[Musique]